all right marshall
marshall where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh born in helsinki
finland in
1974.
you moved to the states i moved to the
states at about nine months old my
mother and father
as the only child for the first 10 years
i guess
what was your childhood like
17 different elementary schools
moved around the bay area a lot
parents were burning out areas
shoplifting and running around like
bonnie and clyde your parents were into
drugs
they did mostly heroin i think
and
they were
they were definitely romantically
enthusiastic about each other and
they fought a lot too but they uh they
were really passionate people
how would you describe your childhood
uh
very unstable
i lived with uh my grandmother a lot
because my parents were either in out of
jail or
running around trying to get drugs or
money
um
my dad liked to drive he didn't drive
stolen cars he'd buy a cheap
cars and
drive him like he stole them
and um
getting a lot of cop chases and
my mother she was uh
she was really good looking for um
i guess uh period she was a good looking
lady
and then um
somewhere along the line she started
losing her teeth
so suffering the effects of the drugs
and and uh
i don't know let's see help me i'll be
out here where was i i lost thinking
about my mom so
you made it through high school
um i did i made it through high school
but not all at one time like um
i did
um
[Music]
i started my attendance started this
summer because i i got into surfing and
surfing
when the waves get good
everything else goes out the window
um
i
ended up testing out with the chspe
which is a
the proficiency exam
and um
i did well i
graduated and
well with the proficiency test i did
like 98th percentile or something like
that
um i was
supposed to be
intelligent as a kid i don't understand
um what their criteria was
but um
allegedly i was a in the 98th percentile
of the
of the aptitude range
and after school what'd you do
uh
what age
high school yeah if you got a did you go
to college after that um i went to
junior college
um
af after uh high school
i went to prison basically oh i said
yeah
uh 18 years old i caught a five-year
term
and
followed it up with a bunch of failures
to report to
parole offices and stuff like that
misdemeanor not even misdemeanors
infractions
um
not even a ticket but
technical violations
i did like nine years and technical
violations on two numbers
um
then got another number in colorado
so i spent 21 out of the next 25 years
after high school in prison
basically for technical violations
one armed robbery when i was 18 and then
a couple minor offenses
drug offenses
and a vehicle code violation got me back
to prison so didn't take much after the
first
trip yeah so drugs started a few what
time
i got into drugs when i was in prison
the first time um
or like right before prison i kind of
was in the rave scene and
like
partying a lot doing
drinking and doing drugs
and uh
got
pretty heavy into it
towards it i guess
late part of my 18th year
um
drugs and relationships like i get into
these
crazy like
all or nothing relationships and usually
just go all out until
we were
completely burned out and i was in jail
and drugs have stayed in your life since
then
yeah they they did they um but i
over the next 20 years
um i kind of like stopped experimenting
with all kinds of different psychedelics
and and
drinking and all that um
i had gotten on uh some opiates for a
while and
i didn't like the fact that i was
a slave to them after that that initial
i just like i felt like it was a threat
every time i tried to to quit is uh
they're gonna they're gonna come make me
sick and and
uh
eventually beat the the opiates with
meth
i think it was a victory yeah and meth
is your drug now yeah yeah a lot of
people replace crack with meth or or
heroin or not
yeah there's a lot of people that used
to do uh like a lot of people that used
to ski the snowboard
yeah i guess that's good
i don't see a lot of snowboards that
used to ski i mean a lot of uh skiers
that used to snowboard though
as i
i don't know maybe i got it backwards
there
but um
i know that snowboarding came after
skiing and it seemed to be better
in most people's opinion
and it replaced it
for
the most part um i associate a lot of
things with board sports because i was a
surfer right
so you you're done on a skid row now
um
i worked i worked with uh one of your
neighbors over here in uh in the shop
buildings uh the
scenery sets
um and
doing like different shop tasks
and
then uh remain friends and i hang out
over there
but i go all over la county and skate
different skate parks
ever since i got kicked out of my my
residence at the uh la grande
um
i was in the housing program trying to
get my my section eight
tell me about the la grand just to go
off top off topic for a second the la
grand just to explain to the viewers
ellie there's they're trying to home a
lot of the homeless
and the la grande is like a really nice
hotel it's like a hyatt
downtown right in the middle of downtown
not skid row that place is skid row on
the inside i know it's the craziest
thing because you on the outside it
looks like a beautiful modern hotel
right and a big one it's probably like
15 floors and on the inside if you do if
you don't
know better like you walk in and all you
see is security
there's really no sign of
but what it is is they took everybody
that's
homeless homeless friends
and echo park and just threw them in a
hotel and then told them they can't talk
to each other
um but what happens is
you got to spend 12 hours a day inside
of this
huge hotel
with all these people and they find ways
it's like a prison
it becomes like a prison and there's
like you know people sneaking into each
other's rooms you got you know i don't
know
i don't want to
throw anybody under the bus that's
currently there or get anybody you know
like rat out anything that's going on
that that get me into trouble but don't
name it they got it all going on there
you know underneath but they just do it
they do it uh
as secretly as possible
and some of the stuff that was going on
there i was a little concerned about
because
when i was high and paranoid and two i
was uh
bored for 12 hours a day in my room by
myself with no social life and after all
that time in prison
um
being lonely i
of course would would see some of the
women around there and
i noticed that they were like that
without fail every time i tried to
involve myself with a woman that they
were either
like under somebody else's
thumb pretty tight
um
somebody that wasn't their parents or
their their husband
[Music]
and uh i couldn't afford to pay for one
so
i just if something goes against my if i
don't bring enough to the table to
to have it even
keel where i own something at the end
then i feel like there's some kind of
problem missing right now no but it's
it's an interesting setup over there
because it's it's literally
a beautiful hotel that is now skid row
on the inside yeah it's yeah
instead of tents they're in hotel rooms
but other than that it's still in the
same staff is pretty pretty interesting
too like because it's run mostly by
salvation army people
and they are uh they got their own thing
going on too but you know they get a
high turnover rate with their their
management and their case
managers um for
reasons that
they interact with the the people there
and the people who corrupt them or or
they'll try to or
they just there's a lot of stress i'm
sure that they deal with too yeah with
the kogit
but um there was a covered breakout a
while back too in the hotel
so it's back to your story you're you're
staying where now
i'm i don't stay anywhere i'm like all
over the place i don't have a legit spot
so i end up
running myself ragged for the last six
seven months i've been
literally like
non-stop
24 hours a day
like either going to some place to skate
skate boarding there on my way back
and then i take cat naps or grab sleep
whenever i can like as if i was at war
in the army or something
in between and it's like constantly on
the march you know i don't if i sit too
too long in one place i'm either
loitering trespassing or wearing out my
welcome right
i don't even have a tent
yeah how do you support yourself
i get uh gr and food stamps
and uh
wash windows at the gas station it gets
real tough
i don't commit crime anymore if i can
help it you know like occasionally uh
i've had to
snag something to eat because i had low
blood sugar going on or an emergency i
let myself get too
worn worn down too far or things
i feel like i get a lot of attention um
like
more than than what would be normal i
think
i got all kinds of theories on that
um but with that attention a lot of
times a lot of pressure
a lot of
opportunities that i would have normally
had
get
sacrificed or pushed out because people
don't want to deal with that kind of
public attention on them
you don't look particularly homeless
i try not to because if i look homeless
i'm going to stay homeless
i try to take care of my hygiene i try
to hope that
um between
not going completely insane and being
um
or total like
recluse
and having decent hygiene i might
have another relationship
where i could meet somebody that that i
have a deep connection with that i'm not
like
um
somebody i don't know
i'm single so
it's tough for me to get into
relationships after 21 years in prison
people just don't relate to that very
well
and i don't know about the dating scene
how like to hook up things work out and
i'll get online and meet people i don't
go have sex with people with strangers
from for
you know whatever reason at strange
hours because they're online
i have like i have to like know somebody
i want to know who they're who they're
who their parents are and like
if their parents know if they disappear
that i was there you know like i don't
want to yeah it just seems weird the
world has changed a bit
yeah it has and like it not for
everybody though i mean if if
if i'm sleeping with a girl like i don't
want to have like some some like
surprise come up and find out that she's
got like this whole other life you know
like
a family or people that that
that i just want to like
be comfortable you know i i don't have
a lot of comfort in my life a whole lot
of positive things but that's something
that i would like to make sure that i
got covered on all ends because i've had
enough sex and meaningless relationships
to like satisfy myself where
um i mean i i did 21 years in prison i
know how to i know the mechanics of
dealing with the physical part of it i
don't need help with that you know
but
it's like uh
it's like anything else you know there's
there's got to be something more to life
and i think part of it might be
starting a family you know do you have
kids no no kids not that i know i mean
there's allegations but
they still only take nine months i'm
pretty sure
and uh most of the allegations didn't
quite line up with the nine-month mark
right
what emotions do you go through now you
get depressed with this life
depressed uh i hate to admit that to
myself but yeah
i don't i don't like to
be a depressed person i i think i get a
lot i get angry and frustrated a lot i
get inpatient
um i get uh
yeah um
i think
cynical a lot you know i have a pretty
interesting
i'd like to think that i have an
interesting point of view
about everything actually
but of course if it was that interesting
i'd probably have more friends
do you have any friends
no i mean i do have lots of friends but
no no real uh
no best friend no just just like
acquaintances that you know from yeah a
lot of acquaintances and a lot of people
that i i could be really good friends
with it's just they're i don't have the
time
that people that are really good friends
have in the past to draw like memories
and shared experiences and stuff like
that
money's a problem
is there any are there any positives to
this lifestyle
to this lifestyle no responsibility no
i don't know any other lifestyle
could apply to my life at this like i i
can't see making different decisions
having improved anything
at this point like that i didn't really
have a whole lot of options that were
good so like most of the bad decisions i
made were because a lot of
bad options were
um
i mean i know the drugs are
not everybody's uh
a lot of people will take the drug thing
and blame all the problems in life on
drugs if you use drugs
but the drugs were a tool that i used to
deal with a deeper problem that i didn't
have another solution for
and i i use them and i manage them the
best i can
try not to get out of hand and after 20
something years of injecting
methamphetamine i haven't come up with
any diseases related to it or
except for addiction apparently as
i've been diagnosed with it but i i
don't do a lot of the things that other
people that are addicts do like i don't
go and steal my friends and things and
sell them for for drugs i don't
spend more than
five ten bucks
a day if that on meth
and
i don't really understand people that do
you know
what do you think is stopping you from
getting a job and
stability id
certainly look employable
i think a lot of it is is
mental block or or
um
possibly just like
there's certain things that it took me
four years to get a physical id from the
dmv
and i only had it for like a month and i
i didn't get a career going in that
month when i had my id yet before i
laid down on a couch
um and
on the way home fell asleep
took a power nap and woke up
got on the bus and realized i didn't
have my id on me anymore somebody stole
it
i left it somebody stole it i'm not sure
i'm not sure exactly yeah the sleep
you're in and you do math yeah deep
sleep right yeah i i just
i was tired before i went to sleep so i
could i could have been absent-minded
what do you worry about
what are you afraid of
i'm afraid
of
this world consuming
these young beautiful women that i see
um
and turning them into
zombies and corpses
there's a lot of them out here
men too
yeah
um i'm not as worried about the men
because i feel that
i was raised in a real
chauvinistic
egocentric male
machismo
type of
mindset i guess
where males were expected to
defend and protect the women
and not exploit them
i kind of feel like
i get a lot of
um inspiration to
involve myself in people's lives i don't
really
need or want that type of
help
or don't know that they do
and the people that they're around
definitely don't want somebody like that
involved
because uh there's a lot of exploitation
a lot of a lot of
trafficking trafficking stuff that goes
on
what's been the lowest point of your
life
other than being in prison
lowest point in my life
other than prison what do you think
how old are you
i 48 or almost 48.
when my dad died it was pretty bad
that was when uh
he was 52 so i was
uh
like 32 when that happened and my
brother passed away uh like
four years ago i think
how'd you lose your brother uh he killed
himself
suicide yeah he
i didn't really have a physical
closeness to him because he lived in
finland but
he was over there with my mom and i was
raised here
i hadn't seen him since since
like the 1980s
in person what was going on in his life
that
i really don't know apparently it was a
obedient addiction
and then i was having trouble staying
with the phone
and we were communicating on facebook
but i fell off because i went to do a
revocation in colorado
and um
then
came out here
um
discharged parole in colorado and came
back home to l.a and
my uncle who lives in l.a
um
he came and visited me where i was
living at lincoln park and he's like hey
um
and a real official
you know he was in the military he was
an aviator for 10 years in the army and
in his most official military fashion
delivered the message about my brother
and
[Music]
i was eating the ben and jerry's ice
cream
i think
a pint
and i had taken like about a bite out of
it
and i just
i don't know
there was a
sunny day in
lincoln park and i just looked at my ice
cream and i threw
high as far as i could
and
started crying like
just not fair you know like
he was 10 years younger than me
approximately and had the world ahead of
him
and
it's like i was
i knew it was like somehow my fault
because i didn't i didn't have a phone
i wasn't
keeping up
communications with them on facebook and
um
part of that that not having a phone
thing and
um
there's like the this
bullying that goes on cyber bullying and
like
what is it group uh
stalking and stuff like that
i've had to deal with some of that type
of stuff that people talk about or at
least some of the symptoms of it i'm not
sure about the actual
people involved i don't
take it personally i think it's i think
it's a social problem not a personal
problem
uh more socioeconomic related but
because of those problems
my brother didn't get the brother that
he needed
in the family to keep him
from making a bad choice when
brothers um
should confer and and confide in each
other
and because i wasn't able to be there
for my brother he killed himself
i didn't
i didn't take him up on top of the crane
in the middle of the winter and throw
him off
the top of the building
into the snow bank
but
i think that if i would have been able
to be a better brother that he wouldn't
have done that to himself
and it hurts
is that how he killed himself yeah
he went big yeah i mean
it's pretty pretty big way to go if
you're going to
jump off something or
you could have like
jumped off
a bucket like a normal person in the
closet with the rope but
he decided the bucket wasn't good enough
so he had to use a crane in the
building
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
love
that you have to live with everybody
um
you can't like
in other words you can't hate anybody
like
even people that you don't like yep
it's a great
all right marshall thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome thank
you the best of luck out here thanks
thanks
you